[Musica]
l'agricoltore sembra una parola
inventata in effetti lo è cioè
attualmente non è ancora presente sul
dizionario magari lo sarà come lo è
stato perpetaloso non mi auguro
in buona sostanza Secondo me Che cos'è
l'agricoltura l'agricoltore e colui che
si occupa e si prende cura di un sistema
che è l'agricoltalco
l'agricolvoltaico è una soluzione
tecnologica che unisce la produzione di
energia elettrica da Fonte fotovoltaica
con l'attività agricola sullo stesso
territorio Con un'unica grande gestione
che è una gestione di manutenzione
elettrica con quella che è l'attività
agricola vera e propria
E dunque mi ricordo era il
2009 io andavo ancora all'università e
si parlava di un concetto arcaico di
agrivoltaico che era quella della Serra
fotovoltaica era
un progetto pionieristico è con le
società di famiglia si cercava di
realizzare questa questo progetto sul
nostro territorio che è l'alto Tirreno
Cosentino in Calabria quindi si
proponeva questa soluzione a vari
investitori compagnie energetiche
soprattutto grandi compagnie energetiche
che molto frequentemente ci sbattevano
il portone in faccia dicendo No non si
può fare troppi innovativa ci sono
troppi rischi troppe responsabilità no
e dunque Noi abbiamo insistito Alla fine
abbiamo trovato
una società una società che era hfv una
piccola società controllata da un fondo
di private Equity molto grande che f2i
allora loro ci hanno detto noi
investiamo sui vostri territori in
questo progetto che è un po' fantasioso
però investiamo ad una condizione dovete
investire anche voi presenti sul
territorio e noi ci siamo guardati
abbiamo detto Vabbè costa tanto
però è una grande opportunità facciamolo
abbiamo avuto fortuna in effetti è stata
una grande fortuna perché questa piccola
società poi è diventata la prima azienda
nel settore del fotovoltaico in Italia
per potenza di fotovoltaico installato
questa si chiama F solare Italia che è
ancora come grande società
Nonostante sia molto grande conserva
quell'imprinting agricolo che è calato
sul territorio
L'innovazione che abbiamo portato è
molto legata alla tradizione perché
prima di proporre queste cose noi
avevamo fatto degli studi agronomici
cioè i contadini erano un po' scettici
dicevano sotto il fotovoltaico non
crescerà mai niente perché la pianta non
fa fotosintesi e dunque non riuscirete
mai a fare nulla però noi avevamo
trovato una cultivar che era tipica del
nostro reale che era il cedro varietà
liscio Diamante considerato sacro da
tutti gli ebrei del mondo tra l'altro
una cosa molto particolare e abbiamo
detto va bene creiamo il solito contesto
facciamo ombra allo stesso modo in cui
si faceva in maniera tradizionale In
effetti questo cedro cresceva sotto
unrai sotto delle Stuoie vegetali
abbiamo unito delle tecnologie nuove di
gestione dell'attività agricola e quindi
abbiamo fatto
un'irrigazione insub e dichiarazione a
microportata era una tecnologia studiata
nel deserto e insieme all'ombreggiamento
dei moduli fotovoltaici si creava un
microclima tale da ridurre levato
traspirato e addirittura Riuscivamo a
risparmiare in impronta idrica e quindi
consumiamo attualmente un milione di
litri per ettaro di acqua contro i 6
milioni di litri per ettaro normalmente
utilizzati nel pieno campo equivale a
dire utilizziamo 16 vasche da bagno per
di acqua per una pianta di limone piena
maturità piuttosto che 96 vasche da
bagno Quindi è una cosa abbastanza
importante e in più facciamo energia
pulita per circa 16.000 famiglie
italiane
che corrisponde
all'abitato urbano di Ragusa
facciamo abbattimento di CO2 per circa
20.000 tonnellate
all'anno
ed è un grande risultato questo equivale
a dire che di spegnere i termosifoni
condizionatori le auto e le industrie
per 12 giorni all'anno nella città di
Catania
Ma uno dei grandi risultati è quello di
dare opportunità di lavoro e opportunità
di attività economica sul territorio
Tanto è vero che molti miei coetanei
sono rimasti sul territorio sono tornati
sui territori a lavorare in un contesto
che adesso è in fase di espansione Tanto
è vero che qui nel pubblico C'è anche
mia cugina che è tornata da Bologna dopo
un periodo di formazione a Torino a
Bologna sta lavorando come ingegnere
nella nostra società e continua a dare a
questa attività il mio socio Marco ha
un'altra persona Giacomo Comunque siamo
un team di persone giovani Prima eravamo
un po' che adesso siamo 60 persone
e
dunque tutti questi risultati ci hanno
consentito di raggiungere
dei
riconoscimenti a livello nazionale e
ci hanno dato un ruolo nel contesto
dell'agricolvoltaico a livello nazionale
tanto da fondare recentemente l'Ajax che
è l'associazione italiana
dell'agricolvoltaicosostenibile
presieduta da Enea che ha il compito di
stabilire
quelle che sono le regole
dell'agricoltalco sostenibile e quindi
di
un po' delineare quelle che saranno le
linee guida e comunque la normativa
nazionale in tema di
agrivoltaicosostenibile
Ebbene ancora ci sono persone scettiche
da questo punto di vista
noi quando andiamo ancora a proporre
questo questo investimento nuovo di
agrivoltaico sui territori ci dicono
Vabbè ma sotto i pannelli non cresce
niente un po' come accadeva nel
2009-2010 e noi li invitiamo a pranzo e
questa è una delle nostre Serre
allestite per il pranzo per la festa
della fioritura
e quindi abbiamo la risposta e dunque
guardiamo al passato quando accadono
queste cose e adesso abbiamo in sviluppo
400 nuovi Megawatt di agricoltura in
altre zone d'Italia adesso siamo
presenti in Umbria nel Lazio in Sardegna
non solo in Calabria
e 400 nuovi Megawatt vuol dire circa
300.000 piante da frutto
l'equivalente dell'abitato di Catania
Quindi tante persone una piantina per
ogni persona
e dunque
andiamo avanti guardiamo il passato ed
immaginiamo il futuro questa è la nostra
risposta agli scettici e in più
immaginiamo che
l'agricoltalco ci sia ci sia nel futuro
e magari anche la parola agricoltore
prenderà il posto nel dizionario Grazie
[Applauso]